c'est un épisode peu connu de
l'importation du chlordécone aux
antilles la disparition pure et simple
d'une quinzaine d'années des archives au
ministère de l'agriculture
ce matin les députés ont posé la
question au directeur général de
l'alimentation bruno ferreira comparer
nous avons effectivement une absence de
comptes rendus entre février 2009 172 et
juin 1989 sur l'équipe pour laquelle
nous n'avons pas pu retrouver de comptes
rendus sur le sujet dans les archives
que nous nous pouvons avoir ministère de
l'agriculture
comment expliquer une telle situation
que le ministère ne puisse pas retrouvés
et compte rendu qui sont de nature
officielle est ce que ces comptes rendus
ont disparu lee min-hee ses archives
aurait permis de comprendre comment le
pesticide a pu être autorisés ici alors
que des alertes étaient émises dès les
années 70 on sait déjà
grâce à deux rapports notamment celui de
pierre joly en 2010 que la commission
des toxiques a refusé deux fois le mot
location du chlordécone en 1968 et 1969
en 2009 le rapport finn ce note même que
le président de la commission des
toxiques insiste sur les potentialités
cancérigène des organochlorés le
chlordécone sera pourtant homologuée
chez nous en 1972
les députés veulent donc savoir si la
disparition des comptes rendus de ces
événements est accidentelle ou
intentionnelle la question en fait
et celle ci est ce qu est l inverse on a
encore des traces des archives
antérieures à 72 et postalia 89
pour bien comprendre et qu'effectivement
il ya eu peut-être éventuellement
quelqu'un à délicat ministère nous avons
des traces notamment s'agissant des
comptes rendus de la commission de
d'étude de la toxicité qui datent de 68
2 69 jusqu'en 72 ensuite effectivement
nous n'avons pas retrouvé de traces
jusqu'en 89
sur la commission d'étude de la toxicité
et s'agissant des autorisations
nous avons des archives qui sont
effectivement assez parcellaires sur un
certain nombre de dossiers
à défaut la commission à ce matin
demandé les noms des gens qui siégeait à
l'époque de façon à pouvoir auditionner
ceux qui sont encore en vie